Well let's watch
Overview of glycolysis
Sugar decomposition is a very important chemical pathway
It happens practically in all forms of life as we know it
It is the taking of glucose as fuel
And by smashing it
Leading to glucose, decomposition,
Break it into two pyruvate molecules
Glucose is a molecule of 6 carbon atoms
Each pyruvate is a molecule made up of 3 carbon atoms
And by doing this
2ATP is produced as a result
In fact, you need to use 2 ATP
And then produce 4
If you are using 2ATP
This is called the stage of investment
We'll talk about it later
And then produces 4ATP
The result is
+ 2ATP
That is what we see here
In sum 2ATP is produced directly from
Sugar decomposition, we also have
NAD returns to NADH
Remember that the return is the acquisition of electrons
Here is NAD, Nicotine Amide
Here is NAD, nicotine adenine, adenine, dichlorotide there are other videos about this
It's an interesting molecule and it's really
Molecule is somewhat large, note
We observe a positive charge, and then see that it has not only gained hydrogen
But also lost its negative charge
They gain hydrogen and electrons
This can be thought of as acquired
Hydride in the aggregate
Of course anhydride anion will not normally exist alone
But by the end you can think that's what happens
If they acquire hydrogen and an additional electron
If NAD + is returned
It will be returned to NADH
The NADH can then
To be oxidized in the electron transport chain
We will study this later, when we think about
When we think of oxidative phosphorylation to produce
More ATPs
But at a high level and simple basis
Glucose is broken into pyruvate
6 carbon atoms to 3 carbon atoms per molecule of pyruvate,
But there are other things associated with carbon
Associated with carbon and we'll see it soon
2ATP is produced in the sum, and also returns
And also returns 2NAD to 2NADH which can be used
Later to produce more ATP
Sugar decomposition is usually just the beginning
For cellular respiration
When oxygen is available, we have these products
Some of these outputs will move to the quantifier
Where there is a loop of citric acid (ring Krebs)
Lemon acid ring (crybs loop) where oxidative phosphorylation occurs
When oxygen is not available, then
Anaerobic breathing will occur
Will enter the fermentation process
We'll talk about this in subsequent videos, if the command is
Understand what will happen to these outputs
Especially the NAD +
Now we have an overview
For glycolysis, let us take a better estimate
Exactly what is happening
Whenever you see these detailed processes
The only thing to be appreciated
Is the complexity of what happens
In all your body cells currently
This is just a approximation
To help us imagine these things, but this
Happens in your body
Millions of times, at the moment
This is nothing
Away from you
And it's fun to appreciate, how
All these things were discovered by scientists
This is a fascinating subject in itself
But the purpose of this video is only
Give an estimate of the real mechanism
Or interaction that occurs
I will not go into details
Mechanisms of Organic Chemistry
We see the glucose molecule here
We see one, two, three, four, five, six carbon atoms
The first step is phosphorylation
We have a complete video on glucose phosphorylation
All these steps are stimulated
By Enzymes
Phosphorylation is stimulated by the enzyme hexokinase
Kinase is a generic term for the enzyme
Which either vibrates violently
Or remove phosphorylation, if it can be said:
It deals with phosphorylation
The enzymes are reduced
Power activation
The way the hexokinase, or part of the
The way it does its job, including coenzyme (Tamim)
A magnesium ion
We talked about it in other videos
On how coenzymes (amulets) help reduce
Power activation
For phosphorylation, we use the ATP molecule
If here 1ATP-
If we are now in the investment phase (Phase I)
But this interaction occurs strongly in the direction of
Left to right, this interaction is associated with where
That the phosphorylation of glucose
You need free energy, but ATP frees energy
We make the horn of these two interactions, and the interaction gets strong
From left to right
Now, let's make sure we understand what happened
These here have been replaced
More precisely here, replaced
With those there
Just to follow what is happening
Now, another reaction is an enzyme booster
This is a reversible interaction in fact
It can get in both directions, but as we'll see, that
The right direction or objects that you follow in
Sugar decomposition, these constantly
Are constantly transformed into subsequent outputs, if
Its concentration will decrease
The interaction will tend to get in that direction
Although this particular interaction, gets from
Glucose-6-phosphate to fructose-6-phosphate
It could be reversible
But the enzyme that stimulates this
Phosphoglobulin isomerase, isomerase
They are enzymes that help in the transformation of the pathogen
Of the molecular to another procession
That's what happens here
Instead of oxygen being associated with this carbon atom
The bond is formed with this atom
If we have fructose, ZO
The pentagonal ring here, excuse us for the constituent ring
Of 5 elements, containing 4 carbon atoms
Against the six-party here
We have 5 carbon atoms
If this bond goes to the carbon atom there
That is the fundamental difference
And then we have an interaction
One-way forward, again stimulated
With ATP, this is obtained by phosphofructokinase
Which contains the word kinase in his name.
It uses ATP, you can guess
What will happen
We will link another phosphate group
To fructose-6-phosphate, and now
We have two phosphate groups.
If this hydrogen is here now
It has been replaced by another phosphate mantle.
Again it is stimulated by
As the enzyme is magnesium, this helps to stabilize
Some special negative charges
Bzamra phosphate, we talked about this in other videos
But the important thing is that they consume another molecule of ATP
We are still in the process of investing
Minus one ATP
And every time I look at this ... it is truly stunning
How all these things happen in your cells
While talking
In fact so I can speak you must get all this
Because my body needs to take glucose and get
On some energy to convert it to ATPs so that my muscles can
To move and to be able to breathe and exhale
And all those things that need to be done so that she can speak
So much as it gets here.
Now in the next step we will talk about
All glycolysis processes are a lysing analysis of glucose
These here are derived from
Glucose and some phosphate
In the next step we will destroy it
We will destroy it with the enzyme
Fructose diphosphate aldolase
Aldolase is an enzyme that stimulates the reactions of aldols
Here, the reaction of aldol can be
Integrates two molecules, or in this case
He will separate them
They will be separated into two seltsin consisting of three carbon atoms
Now these two statins are carbon tetrachloride,
Glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate, this compound is here
This compound here can be converted between them
By another isomerase
It is the isomerase triosphosphate here.
At this stage of glycolysis, we can say
That we have two of these in fact
To transfer two hit glyceride-3-phosphate
So as we progress, let us imagine
This will happen twice per glucose molecule.
Anytime you feel confused, I encourage you
To stop the video.
And see how these parts and these parts
When combined with each other, they can form this here
Now we have another interaction,
It is stimulated by dehydrogenase enzyme.
Dehydrogenase enzymes often interfere
In this case, this returns the NAD.
We saw this in the overview video
If the NAD is returned.
These can be used - this NAD - later
Can be used in electron transmission chain
Possibly producing more ATP
But during the return we add also
Other phosphate group to
Glyceraldehyde-3-phosphate.
As you see this group of phosphate
Here perfectly, they did not exist before
In fact here it is
I had to put arrows on both sides
This is here, that interaction
It can actually get in two directions
In fact this interaction also
And then, now
We will enter the profit phase (second stage)
If this is here, we are starting
With this molecule that possesses
Phosphate, and then
Using kinase phosphoglycerides, we were able to
We were able to separate one of the phosphate groups
During this, production of ATP.
Now we may say that we won the ATP molecule
But we have to remember, that is now
Get twice
Because we have two molecules of glyceride-3-phosphate
If now can be said, if we are talking
For getting this twice, 2ATP +
Now we are in the making.
Then we have a catalyst reaction by
Phosphoglycerides Motaz, Metaphysics
Belongs to the row of isomers (impregnated enzymes)
I have difficulty pronouncing his name
Which will take an effective coterie of place
Or transfer a section of the molecule
To another section, as you see this phosphate group
It moves from this carbon atom to the carbon atom in the middle
This is what the enzyme does
Then we use Ainolas to get here
And then Peruvat Kinase, here
Kinase will be used
To remove the phosphorylation of this molecule here
This brings us to - in this way I drew it -
Peruvian acid, because I painted hydrogen here,
If hydrogen goes, take oxygen
Electron, we would have pyruvate
This is considered the end,
This is considered the end, you might say, the sugar-glycol stream
But what happens, I do not want
I do not want to mention what is happening here
These ADPs are converted to another ATP
But this will happen twice
So this is 2ATPs + other
I hope you understand that it is in the process of investing
We used the ATP molecule here for glucose phosphorylation,
Glucose phosphorylation, and we used another ATP molecule here
Add the second phosphate group
To what was fructose-6-phosphate
And then we reach the profit stage
Where we were able to produce this NADH
In fact these will be two molecules of NADH
Because all this is here
Occurs twice, we can consider that this molecule is here
It is also converted
To Glyceraldehyde-3-Phosphate Now
We produced 2ATP because this happens twice,
We produced 2ATP there
I hope that everything we talked about from the beginning
It seems logical now.